today's guest is uh is a man who
first had me on a podcast as a human
and he is one half of a member of
fighter and the kids
he is an actor an entertainer and
and a knowledgeable man
[Music]
uh today's guest is comedian brian
collins
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
and i will find a song
it would be a special occasion yeah
tim will grab you though let him grab
man he's got a bag of tricks on him
that's why i've been getting lean bro
is that right yeah less to grab bro you
want to get me you better get me by an
organ
because they can't because their hands
just fall off it's like trying to grab a
dolphin or something oh it's yes like
trying to grab
oh yeah it's like trying to grab uh
like like it's trying to grab the the
top of a cave like an old cave
or a piece of marble that's been tread
upon for many many years when you go to
uh
it's like trying to grab diarrhea if
somebody's on an all oil diet
yeah that's possible sometimes when you
go
in the um if you're in like rome or
you're you it there's a well
where people have been getting their
water and the marble is actually worn
away
from where people have been leaning yes
so that's when you know or steps you can
walk in
um oh yeah there's some steps dude in
the old country and you
and you and it's there's an indent the
marble has been worn away from
where people have walked my friend lives
in a
villa like that in in
is he rich or trentino
in the north of italy jesus he used to
be rich i'll spray my neck even saying
that
i know the way they said roberto
oh dude by the time they're done saying
it i'm freaking nude huh
um are we rolling yeah man nice
and i'm not saying that i would take tim
welch i wanna
well that's what you said though but i
said i'll take tim welch
i think that's exactly what you said so
i'd like to
that's sugar shawn o'malley's coach yeah
now i i i rolled with him
when i say rolled with him we did a
little flow grappling a little light
flow grappling
okay on the ground or on the feet just
on the feet and the ground feet on the
ground we go feet and ground we go feet
and ground
and then sometimes i go in the air if
i'm doing kung fu and uh
he's a gorilla now he's a grill that's a
different kind of strength that's a man
who hasn't stopped training and fighting
forever well he likes to sit i know he
has that like a lot of gorilla you'll
see the the
the orangutans they will play in the
trees they'll be milling orangutan
yeah he's a person of the farc trading a
dookie with another one but you'll see
the gorilla's always sitting there
and he just gets into some big beefy
he's like a man orangutan isn't he he
really is yeah because he's a ginger
yeah yeah he's one of the rare ranga
gingers
he's a ranga ginger or uh what do they
call them in australia they call them uh
gangers
gangers i don't think they're awesome
instead of ginger if you pronounce it
ganger oh really
gengas yeah these gangers yeah he's he's
a
different kind of ginger though there's
a brown i'm not saying i will take him i
meant i will take him somewhere if he
needs a ride that's
what i meant i meant i will uber all
right for tim watch look at him though
wow
now tim timmy and so sean
sean sean o'malley it's so funny because
he fights at 135
and and i'm 170
and obviously obviously he'd knock me
out
right now and be like yeah he'd be like
all right let's go up up and then you
know and if god forbid you try to roll
with him because he'd do something like
get you in
an ankle lock or whatever how do you
want to lose you want to fight sugar
charlie if you and i have to fight
how do you want to lose the question is
theo brian how do you want to lose how
do you want to lose
if do you want him do you want an ankle
lock do you want to get knocked out just
just just tell
i think you got to get him in that hard
scarf baby that's the only way to go
well yeah
i know but i know look i there's rumors
out there about sugar shawn's
that he he can kick you and play uh
beethoven on your ribs with his toes at
the same time yes he can like
there's just the level of speed that he
has well he's got
he's got an ass on him see if you can
bring up sugar shawn
o'malley's ass he's got a tail piece
does he yeah he's a thin guy
whereas he likes to wear tight pants as
well he should and he's got an
ass my girlfriend was like he's got an
ass on him
really yeah she was how can you even
have an ass at 135 you got to really get
to 140 to even have that
he walks around probably at 155 160.
that's a good point
you know what i mean yeah i i hope his
uh he has tauros he had a tarsal issue i
think so hopefully his tarsals are
tight now he's having a tarsal issue i
don't really do we have to look at the
ass of this man right now i know
i mean we don't i believe you but i you
know what i i
i feel like i notice if somebody has an
ass and i don't
and there he is fighting josh brolin
right there
yes he did and josh beat him up oh yeah
i know i could see that
i had to say john from a different era
yeah he's from like the mesologic dog
he's from old school i had a bunch of
stuntmen talking about they worked on
old boy i think it's called that that
remake of that crayon
oh the japanese movie yeah korean movie
well
come on we know what you're saying yeah
you know what i'm talking about yeah
and uh they all the stuntmen said that
guy is very strong new brolin
yeah he was he was he's a bull like he
was able to do a lot of his own stunts
they were they were actually shocked at
how strong he was
oh i shook his hand before and it's like
you know when you get up to like a a
door and it's locked yeah it's the same
type of thing yeah like
oh you can't really do much i seen i i
shook
a guy named incognito's hand he plays
yeah yeah
i think defensive tacklers offensive
tackle yeah he called out that gay the
other gentleman who he got an argument
to get
larry tunsil or whatever i think that
was gay yeah he got in trouble for
bullying i think but he's always been a
tough one which you
should do i feel like if your job is
being
this guy yeah now he's so big though
like is that kyle turley's son dude
it might wait go to that that picture
right there where he's got that bill's
hat on
right there look at how look at how just
thick he is oh yeah look at how thick he
is
he's a he's a blonde silverback i
couldn't put my he
he i couldn't put my hand so when i
shook his hand
my hand didn't reach all the way around
his palm so his palm
is two of mine it was so weird and then
did it go both hands
on his hand like i had to go here i had
to go i had to go like this
use one hand as your knuckles and one
hand is your hand i said how much did
you squat how much do you squat he goes
well
i mean i used to when i was going crazy
you know probably i don't know 805.
i went hey you had to add the five
pounds to the eight yeah he got
i think he yelled at tiger woods son or
whatever jonathan martin
jonathan martin there it is um
if you could be a pro athlete at one
sport what would it be um
because you played what basketball
football played basketball
you want to bring up the picnic we gotta
pick here
well when we we call him pit that's his
nickname is picnic
when we when we need a jpeg oh i got you
you know nick was a premature baby do
you know that
he's a tall kid so i'm surprised he got
a lot of you probably pack a lot of milk
as a boy
i did i do love milk back back nick you
come from
i'm gonna guess i'm gonna come i'm gonna
guess you come from scandinavian stock
i actually don't know my family history
that well he was adopted by his
grandmother dude
um i think you're like german irish
what look at look at theo there i am
right there though wow
wow now you're the only white kid on
that team well the other kid behind me
was
white and black okay so you were you
were the minority
in that group yeah you keep in touch
with any of those guys
a lot of these guys didn't have phones
in do they have phones now
some of them one guy was 35 years old
the guy on the top right
he looks like him yeah dude he would
drop his son off at school in the
morning
and then pretend that he wasn't going to
school and then coming to school
it was crazy yeah he looks he looks like
he's got a mortgage
all kinds of issues oh yeah definitely
man damn
basketball funny how skinny we were as
kids oh crazy huh
and then when you're skinny adults go
you're gonna fill out yeah i never
filled out
really no what's one of what is one of
how do you age gracefully i know that
you've been aging or getting into aging
yeah you haven't getting anything and
how do you age gracefully do you
feel like um stay productive sleep
well physically let's start with
physically you see sleep is the most
important
most people are underslept really but
that requires but then if you're going
to talk about
[ __ ] sleep tim welch dude damn dude
sorry dog dude you got i don't know look
you're coming
hard on you're coming hard on tim welch
right now none of this is going to end
well
dude he's not i can feel how mad he is
right now i know the phone's blowing up
tim already hears that i know that none
of this is gonna let you down tim calm
down
yeah i'll talk sense into him i know
that none of this is gonna end well or
age well
damn when there's a video years from now
of tim bucking just
sending me to sayonara yeah yeah it was
just working your body so he doesn't
knock you out at first just hit you in
the liver
yeah hey he'll dress up like a
lumberjack and just literally chop me
down just chop
his axe feet you look like a piece of
wood to me cha cha
um meet my paul bunions he'll dress up
like a woodpecker for halloween and just
show up at a party i'm at
and just take it to my neck he'll just
take his feet and go i got bunions on my
feet time for you meet my paul bunions
and start just kicking you about the
legs your blood clots
and i'm gonna rush you to the hospital
babe the blue blood clot
oh they can kick you when they kick you
down here
or behind the knee that muay thai [ __ ]
you can keep it
they just have different bones we got
corey sanhedrin coming in today
corey sanhagen is corey sandhagen
i i his his coach christian allen i
watched that kid
train before anybody knew he was i was
at high altitude really
and that dude is and how do you get up
to high altitude
you don't have to have ladders to get
into the building or no no no it's just
in denver you just go to denver
oh wow yeah it's cody uh donovan's uh
school
and and christian allen who's a genius a
genius he's a ninja
christian is a ninja wow and christian
allen is that was his protege
i took a couple striking classes from
christian allen which i have no business
doing there's no
there's no absolutely no reason but i
would go back to my boxing gym
and use just some of the [ __ ] he taught
me and it would [ __ ] they'd be like
what is that
it's just he's just like he's he's
this creative savant and cory sanhagen
is a product of that
and cory sanding has been training since
he was 16 years old
i don't see anyone in the 35 pound
division
i mean i all due respect to everybody
there because that's a
stacked division but anybody who fights
san diegan if i had to put my money on
the future champion
i got to be honest it's san hagen well
he looks the
the thing when you're watching him also
he looks like he has another
200 fights in him well he does like he
just does
i think at that weight too those guys
just don't wear down as
as quickly he doesn't take a lot of
punishment number one yeah and he's just
on the move so much
and he's also five eleven five ten
eleven so he's like my height
i'm six four but he's but i slouch and
when i slouch but he's tall
and he gets down to 35 and so
he's doing [ __ ] it's this new [ __ ] you
know i was talking to uh
malik who grew up boxing on larry moloch
no molok b
oh oh yes and larry molly he keeps
changing his name dude it's mallet
you know what i'm saying that's the
weirdest thing sometimes you meet a
black guy who doesn't know how to
pronounce it
i call him malek i don't know i like it
i like this soft a i like
and look honestly seasonally i will
change up
how i do the vowels of his name i will
also call him mala
you know if it's an egyptian holiday
i'll [ __ ] go full moloch on him
malik you know what malik means in
arabic king
no way yeah he is kind of a king man
yeah
um but he was telling me how boxing has
changed when he now
tries to spar with these younger dudes
they're doing [ __ ] he hasn't seen
wow they're doing weird because
everything evolves people come up with
if you're in a gym and everybody's doing
the same thing
you start getting used to each other's
patterns then somebody comes along with
somebody innovates something different
somebody goes i'm going to come in with
a
a lead uppercut like you know and then a
hook and you're like well but that's not
supposed to be that's not what happens
but
he's a he's an unbelievable boxer malek
oh dude try try boxing with that guy i'm
not fighting that guy he'll sleep you
i'm not gonna fight him no but wait we
were talking about
and yeah we were talking about oh sleep
great so the fighter has more
the fighter and the kids has more
fighters on it now yeah
yeah so it's interesting because the
only kids on there is chappelle and
brendan mm-hmm
yeah and then it's you and mala
my mom michael mal
michael what season is it no but you
asked me how i age gracefully
yeah let's get back into that man so
first i want to know physically
how do you age gracefully first of all i
think you have to sleep is everything
okay so but the problem with that is
that people i don't sleep well
well are you eating a lot before you go
to bed what kind of food are you eating
are you on any kind of like stimulants
now what if you have a couple of godiva
chocolates
it depends but as you get older you're
going to have more and more of a problem
as you get older you you could when i
was younger i could drink a bottle of
wine
red wine no problem i had energy i had
energy wow what was it in was it in like
one of those can you bring up a cask of
red wine please
i just wanted i drank it from a cask did
you actually actually you drink it from
a
from a from a leather bladder from that
flask from an old school flower i've
heard
stories of uh yeah if can we get an
image of a cask of red wine
yeah that's a cask i think it's a wine
cask see that
you know what i was looking for i was
looking more for the
an old timey old a cask is what you you
transported in maybe or just you store
it in or you age it in but
but uh a flask you use a leather
a leather flask you know i'm thinking
yeah more like that bladder that more
like
that would probably change the taste of
the wine you see you understand
so you need what you need is you need a
glass bottle
you age it under preferably fifty-five
[ __ ] wants to pull out a glass bottle
with his buddies you guys are all on a
mountain side relaxing
yeah the women are walking you know if
they want to
do it are doing washing down by the
creek or collecting berries or
yes if it's a traditional if it's a
traditional hike
they're gathering and you guys are
hunting right i mean right everybody's
playing there everybody's doing helping
out and there's a room for the other
person there are
other genders that might be represented
there who might do both right
right or who might choose right to do
yes
maybe one day the biggest hunter's like
oh i'm going to go hunt berries you know
like whoa that's right calm down a lot
yeah
we need you back up here dog um
yeah but you so okay so sleep water
and then um i think i actually believe
in now do you do water before you go to
sleep
sometimes but i think more importantly
is in the morning and then what i think
is important is
not eating too much never overloading
your system
never so if you i do think uh
intermittent fasting is a really good
idea
wow and i think eating simply and not
overloading your body
you can feel it dude i've done i haven't
done intermittent fasting but i've had
mittens on before and it's so hard to
[ __ ] eat with mittens
and that's the same goddamn thing yeah
how are you supposed to butter your
toast with mitt roll dude
it's impossible and then you're spitting
out whoop
damn it and it's like at least they're
wool though and why do you wear wool
when you why do you wear wool when
you're hunting because you are trying to
attract animals
no because you need why would you wear a
wool instead of cotton
i would wear wool instead of cotton
because wool is warmer
well it is especially when
when it is nighttime when it gets wet
when it gets wet yeah
so wool gets wet better yeah if you
cotton kills
you if you get wet and cotton you're
gonna die
if you get wet and wool will will
actually keep you
warm it acts like almost like an
insulating like a like a
it's almost like a uh wetsuit so you'll
stay alive longer and wool
you don't want to be wet period but
we'll so that's why
your first two layers when you go
hunting or in the wilderness is always
wool
you don't you can use polyester maybe
but you want wool
i don't want to do i want to do if i'm
going outside i like to have one wool
socks
actually if i'm on a long distance
flight i'll even wear wool socks yeah
that's where i'm at age-wise i got all
kinds of things about i'm terrified of
the cold i'm afraid of the cold cold
makes me a coward
so i always have warm [ __ ] in my car
including
fire making material oh yeah you know
what i'm saying
so does that so i guess i do but
not really i mean if i can you know you
live in venice
in case venice goes enough homeless
who's making fires i know but in case it
goes to the wolves
maybe the vegetation sure there's a
virus and vegetation gets crazy and now
we're in
this tropical jungle because of global
warming and now i got to make a fire
here's a question right here man from
peter peteryon
son hey peter take your hood off damn
kid
what's up brian what's up theo coming
here from los
angeles uh i ran into brian about two
years ago in venice
was too much of a [ __ ] to say what's up
my biggest regret in life pretty much
but uh
speaking about i didn't see you i would
have said yeah brian you can talk about
no he said he was a [ __ ] for not saying
hi to you oh okay
but i respect the fact that you thought
he called that you were the best i
always say hi i'm always super nice
gym vibes a lot of homosexuality there
um hey man brother a lot of people
touching people in odd places
uh you have any experience with that
maybe some tips on how to uh
navigate the waters and just get your
workout in yeah
true alpha like brian would know uh
thanks and he was talking about
specifically the venice golds
yeah well i'm very very appreciative of
that question because i was working out
in the
golds in hollywood when i was a young
man i was cute when i was young man i
knew i was getting older because gay men
stopped looking at me oh yeah
now when i was younger they just give
you money at that point yeah when i was
younger i was skinny and i but i had a
pretty face i had a pretty i had a
delicate nose and mm-hmm
my jaw was well defined and oh damn
write this down man
i had heavy eyelids i had not not heavy
eyelids but you could see the
i just oh yeah you can see the medium
even though i just had my lids it
doesn't work you know so i had i i was
cute
and i was doing i was doing these i
never liked lifting weights i just like
whatever but i'm there and i'm doing i'm
doing whatever those are unique too
those are those kind of like i'm a
kangaroo look at me
you know that's for your triceps i never
could do i hated working out where i was
just doing curls i was like i can't do
it i want to do something with like
where i'm i feel like i'm i'm becoming
more athletic not
not looking like a bodybuilder right so
i'm doing this stupid bodybuilding thing
and a guy gets behind me
he gets behind me he goes doing it wrong
a white guy
yep you're doing it wrong what's up and
he goes get your butt in there
and he kicks my knees and he grabs my
elbows and i'm like
i don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
here man so we just went with it
we dated for like three years i know and
then i was like i'm straight and i ran
out
i was like i can't do this anymore but
you get confused
the answer to that question is you're
gonna sometimes you can get like what
the [ __ ]
and you're living with each other you
have two small dogs you have a vegetable
garden and you're like
i'm not gay but it can take a while it
can take a while because it's
comfortable they can they
it can get comfortable when you're
shacked up they lull you in with the
wind chime you go to their house and
there's wind chimes
and some of the wind chimes it's other
young men screaming for help when the
wind hits the pipe
[Music]
i've been attracted to um there's a guy
yesterday that's crazy but i'm like
where did you
get that wind chime dude and why does
each chime have a person's name written
on you have somebody
somewhere in this house is there
somebody under the floorboards how do
you know um that's
edgar island ho man yeah it is that
growling telltale heart
god damn right brother is in the
floorboards
um okay so sleep and water helps
but you but yeah to get back this man's
question sorry
a lot of men and look one thing that's
not discussed a lot of times in america
is the aggression of
it's always looked at that men uh
straight men are the predators in
america
there is also predatorial behavior by
gay men
and it is unchecked there's nobody
monitoring it
yeah there's nobody uh it's kind of guy
crime so geyser
right but you see how i i i think you
can quickly see how women are
disgruntled by the behavior of men
sometimes by men flirting with them
because it happens so aggressively with
men
you know yeah that's very true it's just
it's tough to like
and there's no and you gotta if you're a
supermarket at whole foods and you're a
good looking woman
you know you're gonna be dealing with
energy
yeah it's like it's like it's almost
like being a celebrity where
you know all those people want to talk
to you and you're not going to
something's going to happen yeah you
know what i mean like
you're going to have to you're first of
all you're aware of how you look because
you have to because they're staring at
you
you know they're going to look for an
excuse to talk to you they know you know
they're going to try to stop you
it's all that exciting it's like being
on a decent podcast
it's like being on a decent podcast it
really is love your podcast bro and then
they want to take
yeah god bless but you know it's
different for women for guys it's like
ah you know they like me but
right right but for women yeah there's
more of uh exhausting i bet it's
exhausting but then you also get
dangerous like guys who
follow you and [ __ ] there's always that
danger i think for
women where men don't have to deal with
that men men can always
it's just different right if a dude
follows you back to your place you can
like hey dude what are you doing in my
place
yeah whereas women it's more like yeah
it's got to be it's probably a lot
scarier
yeah but it's getting if a guy could
follow you back to your place you know
as a guy you can be like well
make sure you close the door whatever it
is yeah yeah can i get you a drink
yeah um can i get you a uh but wait so
so aging gracefully um is that what we
were talking about i know you were
trying to answer this question i was
trying to answer this guy's question
because i feel like this doesn't get
talked about enough that there is mans
that will do anything to be gay with you
and a attractive here's what i realized
the other day
the hottest guy that a gay male can get
is a straight male i've heard that from
other games no the hottest girl that's
their hottest girl like our hottest girl
is like a hot girl it's like i gotta get
a hot girl
the hottest girl for a for a gay man is
a straight guy
that's their hottest girl turning a
straight guy
yeah yeah and like
people were like yeah it's like first of
all the term
turning a guy straight sounds there's a
physical [ __ ]
element to it it sounds like a [ __ ]
crime
yeah i don't know i i it's still a guy
i've seen women like there was a guy
yesterday i saw who was uh
host of uh he was like seating people
and he was tall he was dressed
so well and he was so effeminate he
smelled so good
and he had short blonde hair and he was
just like he was perfect and he had
really delicate features he was
beautiful he looked like a beautiful he
was so androgynous
like a little layla and he was super
nice and he had a kind of a very
non-threatening voice and you and i was
looking at him and i was like
i'm definitely i'm drawn to this this
this might be a man but he's
got so much feminine energy that's rome
that's that roman vibe
yeah that you're like you're like you
know it wasn't that i wanted to have sex
with him but i
appreciated how beautiful he was as a
creature i'd feed him olives yeah i'd
never i didn't even know i was like i'm
not gonna call him a guy or a girl this
is where the gender fluid thing yeah
makes sense and that's where we're
headed i feel like well
i have a theory on all of it like right
now we're trying to deal with this
non-duality right so you know you know
the idea behind
so so a lot of this this gender stuff
comes from
jack there who talked about so when you
have you have a dualistic mind most of
us have a dualistic mind
i do probably i don't know male female i
do you know
male female reason passion like you know
oh yeah i have all that
logic superstition yes we break up we
break the world up into two
male female yin and yang hot and cold
and what derek said i think he was i
think darren i was [ __ ] the biggest
mental masturbator of all time but what
he said was
he said if you have a dualistic sense of
mind you
automatically privilege one over the
other
you automatically are going to privilege
male over female maybe hot over
there's a tendency to privilege so
reason over passion be reasonable be
logical don't be superstitious
when we have this um uh be the mind over
over the over the heart you know that's
always the battle
the mind or the spirit over the flesh so
we think dualistically
and so the idea is when you do that
you're going to always favor one it's
it's
we are we construct as human beings
maps of meaning and you're going to
always favor one over the other
and when you do that automatically
if you if that's your language structure
there's going to be built-in
prejudice there's going to be a built-in
power structure
you understand and so so the idea behind
a non-dualistic way of thinking the idea
behind
going beyond male and female for example
and gender
is the idea that that's how you and
beyond beyond going black and white
you know the idea is racist non-racist
how about anti-race the idea
is that you will sort of not
favor one over the other and maybe
there's value in favoring the one that
you
usually don't favor over the other right
you got to switch it up so you [ __ ] with
your brain
right so that you [ __ ] with the entire
power structure right that that would be
the idea behind that's what's going on
in the universities
that's what's going on in the humanities
that's what jordan peterson talks about
that's why
you have this huge fight with gender now
right so so now now you have it's very
interesting because the feminists
are having a big problem with the
transgender community because for a lot
of feminists they're going wait
you're saying you're you're a man you're
a biological man but you're saying you
identify as a woman
and so now you're you're trying to be on
equal footing with
women meaning for example you should be
able to compete in women's sports which
means women who are biological get their
scholarships taken away because you
might be physically
just more advantaged you're a man so
it's very interesting to see how the
feminist movement is grading up against
the trans movement it's becoming this
whole
it's becoming this whole crazy [ __ ]
wnba
yes maybe bro out of the game yeah but
no i feel like it comes from a
philosophy a french philosophy it comes
from foucault it comes from
derek i mean if you look at the fathers
of these these kinds of thoughts it's
very interesting
so so you're saying that like because we
got stuck in this old idea of
black or white male or female that
now things it's starting to become the
picture is becoming like
muddier but we're still kind of chained
to some of these old ways
we are because that's the way our brains
work right right and i don't know if
some of it's evolutionary or biological
i would imagine a lot of it's
evolutionary
but right a lot of evolutionary a lot of
it is like us
because yeah a lot of the things i hear
and read these some days it's like
this just this sounds cool it's a neat
idea
but it's not gonna flow actually flow
through
the system that i am making when you get
to the level of detail it's really hard
to implement
right but i have to say that like as
somebody who felt very uneasy about all
this woke [ __ ]
i will say this like i do i know that if
you watch commercials now it's always
like it's always a mixed couple right so
it's like a black
man with a white woman a white woman oh
totally man and so
so the the there's this there's this
this
forced sort of diversity inclusion thing
but what i like about that in a way
is that it is kids are growing up with
the idea that
that's the normal right it used to be
with my generation if a black and a
white person got married it was already
it was always like you you're like oh
you call them zebras yeah
yeah and now it's like what what the
left wants to do
and i understand it is is kind of try to
erase all that from your mind
you don't see color and don't even see
gender because if you make it an issue
the problem is when you try to do that
you're actually making an
issue so that that's the trap that you
have to get out of and i don't know how
to get out of that
but i do appreciate i will say that in a
lot of ways
a lot of this woke [ __ ] is made like so
if you're trans if you're a child and
you do have have this gender thing going
on like you're a man but you feel like a
woman
i really do believe that's a biological
thing i do believe that there are some
people that just
are born that way they're born into a
male body yeah they're born into a male
body but they feel like a woman
there's so many people dude i used to do
it when that shania twain song would
come on if i'm real honest with you
i would be honest i would close my door
and do the damn well we all have
foot on the floor we all you know
there's it's all a spectrum some people
are more feminine more masculine right
and we certainly get caged into
what is expected there's a lot of
conditioning in the world for sure
like this is the way i'm supposed to be
and so
yeah i think it's well it's a there's a
lot it's a it's a lot to
to piece apart it is because but i think
that what i think
is technology and gene editing
and and meshing with computers if you
read the singularity is near
you know human beings are going to start
being able to not only control their own
biology their own evolution
but they might be able to control even
their own
i don't know if it's sex but but the
idea of transforming
into what you actually want to be
through gene editing as an adult
is not far it's not far-fetched
it just isn't you will be able to
eventually
right now the the process of turning
into a woman is crude
right it's hard it's it requires a great
deal of
surgery and things like that stirrups
and all that stuff
i think eventually what's going to
happen is when we have the technology
you think you'll be able to adjust your
genes in real time yes to genetically
you know you will be able to genetically
morph into
the female the biological version of
yourself
as a female and that's not that's not
at all unscientific now now we are
already going to be how would we talk
about gender
now so a lot of this is almost like this
i always try to look at these big trends
as as evolutionarily it's like it's just
there's an evolution to it
there is right well sometimes it's it's
harder like with with
media and like them pushing people
certain ways it's hard to sometimes know
what is like
just where things are going and what is
like okay lead
the people trying to lead you over there
for like commercial value you know
well like that's a hard thing to notice
sometimes but yeah i think as like
i can't imagine if you could press a
button or
take a tonic or something and over like
a week
period you'd be like yeah i'm [ __ ]
yeah i'm doing drywall
right now but in a week i'm going to be
a [ __ ] at least an aide in florida
you know a female 8 and you wouldn't say
that you wouldn't easy
you would be and then you see your
buddies down there who's doing drywall
he's down there because he got a
different job he got relocated
and you guys just see each other in an
elevator yeah that's already
happened but now it requires a great
deal of surgery it's very rudimentary
they call it
yeah it's it's physical and rudimentary
and i mean it's a real
hacksaw jim duggan in there you
basically yeah look and then here you go
right here now
this this guy this this is gabrielle
ludwig it recently went viral people try
to say this is just happening uh she's
playing for santa clara
community college but it was actually
from 2012 but she was a former navy seal
okay come on yeah really yeah usa today
profiled her struggles of being on this
team but
again back in 2000 she's already a
one percenter when it comes to men
biologically right she's six
three or six four eight six eight and
she was a seal
six eight is too tall for a seal i think
right and so there's these other girls
naval tattoos so yeah she first of all
she could
ex-navy soldier not seal sorry yeah
sorry
and professor or senator not senator um
admiral loebwig could easily be some of
these women's fathers
okay how old is 50 at the time she was
50.
50. when she died dude she [ __ ] got
her dime on and [ __ ] balled out what
is going on here like i
to me look i've long said white men
should be allowed to play in the wnba
i've lost as have i but that's not a
white man that's a white woman
theo right now it is platformed but but
here's what's
i think also a lot of our like the
structure we know so far like all the
rule books are male based and female
based like
there's a lot of people that don't want
to like you get stuck in the patterns
and of what was
of what the way things have been it's
hard to be like
okay now we're going to just change it
up you know
well and change takes time too i'm not
against it it's just like
yeah but wait a minute if you're a
mother uh-huh and you've dedicated your
whole life
to getting your daughter to practice yup
and to get a scholarship because you
don't have the money you need the money
mm-hmm
and your daughter's really gifted a
tennis or she's really gifted at
wrestling or she's really good
for singing like selena well no singing
is not an example i'm talking about a
sport
she's she's she's she's still a body
sport not a throat scholarship to
basketball or track
okay and a man a biological man says i'm
now a woman i'm not gonna get any i'm
not even gonna get any estrogen
i'm just a woman i identify as a woman
and goes and uh decides to
compete and takes that scholarship away
from your daughter
you can understand how frustrating that
would be that would be heartbreaking for
the
mother and for the daughter yeah and
also why feminists
now go wait wait wait wait wait we've
been fighting so hard
how do we navigate this right how i
don't know how to navigate it
the turfs exclusionary radical feminists
well so so then if you bring that up
though you're called a transphobe or
you're
no no no no no that's not fair either
we're just trying to solve a problem and
bring up an an
issue that is real so now what do we do
about that
like what what do you do about that [ __ ]
i i don't want somebody who feels
different or feels like they're a woman
or a via vice versa
but they were born another sex yeah i
don't want them being excluded
right but at the same time you know
they can't be cheating and just putting
a camara on every freaking
you know chicken at 105. that's what's
yeah that but that's kind of what's
that's the dilemma right it makes sense
because you're making a lot of rules
where it's like
okay whatever you identify as that's
what you can play as
so of course some people's going to bend
the system you know what i'm saying yeah
but that's a political
that's also an ideological and political
stance
so if you can just identify and whatever
you say but that's what it's getting to
be well so whatever so
then that means that your whatever you
you
conceive and conceptualize right is
truth
then this is dereda then there's no
truth so in other words
if we don't have a standard on which we
can
stand if there's not a standard that we
can more
that we can anchor into right just so
that we can
know that we can distinguish of course
life is
this you have to have that well but but
but no because there are a lot of
there's a philosophy out there
and it comes from darada and and that
says
no there should be zero categories it's
why the maoists
put everybody in the same uniform
and with the same haircut it was the
idea of
eradicating literally any distinction
but mother nature is going to have her
say in that of course she is
you know it's of course she and also the
number this is what gets me
the number of people that
it applies to to immediately take that
template
and put it against the the
bill the the major the mass majority
and then a lot of times they try and
force it in immediately
that's the kind of [ __ ] where you get so
much rebuttal because it's disrespectful
to just
force it immediately i know it's
disrespectful also too it's a little bit
more than that buddy
if you even talk about this if you even
now if you were to if you had the point
of view say you had the point of view
that
there are two sexes or that there that
your biology is what sticks
okay you'll get de-platformed you're
considered
you're you're you're practicing hate
speech and you will be
de-platformed from everywhere including
youtube
really and patreon anywhere else so we
can think stuff like that we can't say
it you're not you're not allowed to
speak
so where do you say it you just go and
chisel it into a bench the first
amendment doesn't really
exist anymore damn and that's a very
dangerous
sign saying it's very dangerous
and nobody i don't think enough people
are talking about it and i certainly
don't think enough people
who are pushing this narrative really
understand what's what
no a lot of people are just chasing
clout they're chasing uh
weenie and and vagina they just want all
they want any type of [ __ ] body you
know genital clout
but what i'm saying is have a separate
league for these for
the middlemen of the universe yeah you
know
because yeah it's like if if i'm uh
a young lady who's worked my butt off
and is about feminism you know like
women we need the opportunity this and
that um
and then a fella comes along
and he but you have lawyers on the left
who are now calling this they are
they're on the left they they fight for
a lot of you know
a lot of liberal causes i can't remember
the woman's name but she's a champion of
she's a left-wing lawyer and she's a
champion of all these causes the social
justice causes
and she said she said this is misogyny
and i was like damn she said it's
misogyny if it's a man and
if it's a transgender person she was
saying that that for men to come into
women's sports now
like this but these are men well she was
saying that that these are rooks
biological men who are coming into
female sports
because they identify that you know they
identify as women now
she was saying you know you hear the
women on the other side you hear
feminists
now fighting that right so it's a fight
man
i just sit back and i'm like damn and
then you got science put him at straw
weight look i say
get him at a weight where is there a
weight class you could get them at
if you say specifically ufc yeah is
there a weight class you could get them
at where it would be
where it evens out a little bit yeah but
the problem with that is that you've got
a different bone
structure and you've got like so so when
you're talking about
punching people in the face and speed
and all that
yeah and even even they even i think
women and men have a different um
read on on split second timing so
uh women tend to hesitate even the high
champions hesitate just a split second
oh women in an instant than men do yeah
and so that's a huge advantage in
striking
so you've got so many issues so when
you're talking about women in
fighting you're talking about
transgender women and fighting
what stage are they at like what stage
that in their transition
how much estrogen they have in relation
to testosterone do they still
have the different bone structure and
the different muscularity that that
gives a man much bigger
i think they there should be then a
separate league or something and i hate
to separate it but it's just
it's when you start catering to
you have to cater to the masses first
it's just
i feel like it's where you have to it's
the most people
you know it's like it's like the same
when you get all these people to
reconfigure their bathrooms and do all
it's like
there's nobody transgender in this town
but you're gonna
have a news media come here and say
these bathrooms are for men only well
you know there's only 11 people in town
people are trying to piss
yeah in some ways that's the strength of
this country though like in some ways
maybe in and i'm not trying to be
old-sided i just think
you have to like yes you welcome them in
and you find a way to do it
but it can't be immediate and that's
sometimes that where i think the media
fails
is they want it immediate they want it
now and
well i think the better way to put it is
that you you want to protect
the marginalized and the minorities
rights right
right not at the expense of other rights
and that's the balancing act so if if
you're
if you're trumping other rights
or you are discriminating against
another group to make room for this new
group of victims or whoever you consider
to be
marginalized right now you're just now
you're just moving money from one column
to the other but you're not really
actually making the world more equitable
right you're you're actually so so so
the idea would be
if you have to have california if you're
a public traded
company in california you had to have if
you had a board of
seven if you had a board of five two had
to be women if you had a board of seven
four or three had to be women they just
enforced that right so you have to have
women
on your board now they want color now it
has to have diversity so if you are
if you're the boy if you represent the
board you're on board of a company
which makes decisions for the company
okay it's a publicly traded company yeah
you now have a diversity quota and you
now have an this is enforced
i don't know if they got the diversity
quota through post but they did with the
female quota so the board cannot be all
male no matter what
so if you have so so the idea is if
you're really qualified for the job but
you happen to have balls
you know and a dick or whatever or a
certain chromosome
you are excluded you can't damn you got
to take a backseat so now now you're
discriminating against men
for having perhaps biology and now you
have to have a conversation about
biology and if you're going to have
if you're going to enforce biological
women are allowed have must be on the
boards
well now what about what about
genderfluid people
what about are you going to represent
transition that is why you relocate to
another state where they're not that's
what happens
right because it's just don't know how
to do business that way because if you
have a business
and you and you're you're responsible
your shareholders you go wait i want the
best people i don't give a [ __ ] what
they
are i want the best people on the on
yeah especially if it's a small
family business now you got your son
cutting his penis off just so we can
work at the shop
you know what i'm saying like no but
this is publicly traded you're going too
crazy
okay my bad man but yeah it's just like
but it just feels like that as a small
business owner you feel like well if my
business ever grows i'm gonna have to
[ __ ] you know
you know get you know i have to install
a dick on my wife just to [ __ ] make
ends meet over here
but that paranoia in your head as a
business person
you're like i'm gonna go to a place the
government comes in and forces you to do
that that's
that's mandated and and so now what
you're doing is you're enforcing
equality
yeah you're enforcing equality of
outcome not equality of opportunity
and what they're doing in hollywood if
you want your movie to be in
in the oscars now being oscar oh yeah
you need to have an amoeba in there
you got to have you have you have to
have color in the cast but you have to
have color
behind the scenes too now but it's
gotten which look i think it should all
be
i kind of believe it should all be based
on just the percentages of the people
that are in the country like
you know if the if ethnicity is a
certain percent then that
percentage should be in trouble with
that because i think oh my god it's
terrible idea
terrible idea because because then then
then you're then again
all you're doing is looking at numbers
and p you
you need the people that get a job
should be the ones who are the best for
the job
right i agree that's what it is if if if
most of the people that are great for it
yeah if most people are great for the
job
are all black women then all black women
should be in there
right if it's all asian and all asian i
don't give a [ __ ]
whoever's best for the job man yeah and
have blind auditions the way they did
so with with uh orchestras they were all
male so they started just having blind
auditions so you couldn't see if it was
a man or woman playing that instrument
yeah you go behind a curtain and play
and you just have to
guess what women now represent even
more than half of the uh of the
instrumentation
in uh i think the san francisco
philharmonic and the new york
philharmonic oh yeah you see a lot of
those harmonics a lot of ladies out
there a lot of dimes out there playing
the flute on the uh
liar do you play an instrument uh what
did i play a little bit of piano
oh yeah yeah for real i'm getting me a
little huh i got me a little
nice little place over there and um at
the moment in nashville i gotta place an
airbnb
airbnb i'm keeping my place here but i'm
getting a nice piano yeah i'm gonna take
you are you gonna be there
uh march 3rd i'm doing another live
podcast you are
another live podcast martial at zany's
yeah
oh well i know i i forgot yeah i i got
to start promoting it
i'll be there me and steve byrne we got
travis trick coming on we got jordan
peterson coming back home oh really
oh man i love that guy pretty excited
about this here's a beautiful lady right
here or uh or
she is this could be a man i have your
jordan peterson book too
you do awesome thank you i love that
book he's got a new one coming up oh i
got to read that yeah
hey theo hey brian my name is marissa um
brian i know that you speak french
um and i do a little bit too and i
actually saw you
in dallas and i thought your whole
french bit was hilarious
um so my question is
francais
uh uh t-fat k um
so into the answer let me know
let me say first language french and um
i know what you said you will return
so thanks guys beautiful lady thank you
for the question i want to say that
young lady appreciate you
all um
um yeah so i went to school in i went to
friends schools
in lebanon when i was a kid and uh
war-torn lebanon huh that's right i was
in the war there for
for about seven months we were evacuated
to greece and then uh i will be
i i've already [ __ ] fell apart
everywhere you go kind of [ __ ] falls
up across the park dude
yeah not to say that with you right here
but no but i was doing some cia work i
was
i was organizing coos oh yeah yeah dude
brendan's still coos sometimes that guy
is [ __ ] the worst vocabulary i've
ever
heard he's the only one him in boston
will talk
but boston will lead the conversation
it's unbelievable
boss i haven't seen i met boston you
haven't no
fine as [ __ ] bro hey take it easy
just stay cute don't say fine bro you're
talking about a baby
bro but this baby is about that
lifestyle no no no i don't know this
baby comfortable with this this baby's
been at pool parties dude i'm not like
you no no
the baby's big though baby's got a head
on him the baby's got a freaking
he's gonna be his biggest daddy oh that
baby is fine
yeah hey hey hey hey no that baby's cute
that's cute yeah baby
i don't like the way you're not dragging
out your words bro sorry don't say cute
with like four u's and
you can't do that bro and you're wiping
your mouth right now
i'm not comfortable
damn man yeah you're right bro thank you
for the question uh sibu play
she's
[Music]
[Laughter]
don't say my girl let him decide
okay you're right i did i don't know how
he identifies yet
but i think he identifies as a boy at
least we gotta let him
you gotta let the parents decide for the
child and then let the child when
they're
older but i mean it's like boston the
best in the boston strangler if he goes
in the ufc
boss that's right best name he's
actually good already boston the
straggler
yeah um so we got a new website done
and uh and i like it i love it you do
yeah super functional yeah it's that's
it that's it it's functional
and it's reliable in the sense that if
we need help with it
this company is right there to do it and
this company is called
modify um what did they do that's
different than the old one
they just added basically all the
functions we
were looking for to fit our podcasts we
can upload video questions
songs voicemails and it's all in one
spot and it's
specific features we ask for so maybe if
you have a different company they can
put features you need
for you right so if you have a company
if you have a design a plan
something you need a website you need
some real estate
on the web well the group that can help
out is called
modify that's right modify
h m-o-d-i-p-h-y dot com slash theo
and they are basically offering the last
website
you will ever need there's no cost to
build
no contract unlimited updates unlimited
supports
custom design easy editing tools
future redesigns all for just how much
nick
i'm actually not sure because i don't
have the copy in front of me 249
dollars a month unbelievable imagine how
much fun you can have
with a website that's constantly going
to be updated 249 dollars a month
they did our website theovon.com they
did a great job and we know it's in
reliable hands
look you got to have real estate and you
got to have it on the web and that's
where your business
needs to be modify.com
theo m-o-d-i-p-h-y dot com slash
theo for the last website you'll ever
need
all right dude we got to get you a hood
hat man
do you got any lacrosse wisconsin any
wisconsin at all
i mean i think there's like a is there a
dekalb dubuque what
is there la la
what am i thinking of in wisconsin um
le clerc no look lacrosse no there's
some other place
fond du lac uh fond du lac sounds
illegal
um i wouldn't want to be a child growing
up there but anyway
uh hood hat is a company that basically
you can go to their website
and you can customize a beautiful
merino will wool cap
that will take that will kind of take
your head to the next level you can pick
out
um colors that kind of fit your vibe fit
your hood basically
so you would do where lacrosse lacrosse
if they had one
i'd i'd rep some of the bigger cities
mke a milwaukee hat
okay what about your neighborhood what
neighborhood do you grow up in in la
crosse
the south side i don't know they didn't
really know she might go
south side lacrosse where i'm from i
might go uh
let me think mcgee street um or i might
just do covington louisiana
or i might do mandeville it can it can
depend you know like but you can
customize it to fit your hood
you know like why make a hat that's just
general los
angeles or uh russia
get something that's very specific hood
hat helps you do it
just go to hoodhat.com and use code
t-h-e-o-20 for 20
off at checkout go to hoodhat.com
use code theo 20 for 20 off
at checkout it's the essence of your
neighborhood the essence of your culture
fine-tuning get specific your street
your block
your hood wherever you're from your
stoop your valley your holler whatever
it is
hand down hands down the best snapbacks
made from the finest merino wool right
here in the usa
hoodhat.com code theo
20 for 20 off and now back to the
episode thanks nick
you're welcome thank you yeah man it's
uh
i guess you're right because now the all
the whole discussion has come back to
full circle
where it's like the original argument is
now butting up with
it's just going to become a spiral
that's it's a never ending
so how you figured out in the west we
figured out a way around this stuff
i mean i'm not saying the west didn't
have its share of
all kinds of prejudice and all that but
the west has done a really
at least the west is the first country
to talk about it and tackle it head on
yeah and and respect the rights without
killing
killing people that's again so so you
know so so but but the west the idea the
idea
on saying we've implemented it very well
but much better than any other country
the idea is you treat people as
an individual if because because if you
start
categorizing people you'll never run out
of categories
yeah i mean if you want to include men
and women on the board and that's
mandated
what about what about people under four
feet tall
what about dwarves what about dwarves
what about
um what about people who have who are
deaf
where are we we need to death man where
are we going to stop this what about the
blind
you you are going to what about trans
are are you going to have are you going
to have to have
represent every category you would never
run out of categories
why you treat people as individuals if
you have a meritocracy it's the only way
at the level of detail
to run a society you can't do it any
other way
yeah and and when you and also i don't
mind if you have a company and you don't
even ask people
i don't think you should ask people of
sexual orientation or any of that
because
obviously who cares well obviously you
don't want to give somebody a reason to
discriminate so don't make anything
right yeah that's the thing it's like by
not yeah it's like everything has just
become such a thing it's imp it starts
to feel impossible to even communicate
and the tough part is that you know i
say a lot of times that tech tech is the
new fossil
fuel you know it's like bandwidth is the
new oil it's like
we're all slaves yeah and it's like
we've
and it's monopolies man they're oh it's
insane it's absolutely insane
but i wish that someone would come out
with an app and but the problem is they
wouldn't be able to platform it now
that would tell you which companies
support which what their beliefs are
that way you could start to have dual
company you know come
people that aren't as yeah you can start
a competition where then it's going to
be like
okay yeah i'm like i might have some of
these beliefs but also some of these
beliefs
i want to support a company that has
more beliefs like i have you know
um wow but then i i just feel like you
i don't know then it would start to
affect the company's pocketbooks and
then you wouldn't see so many companies
i feel like be so outspoken
make their employees feel like they have
to vote a certain way or this type
yeah like i worry about i wish there
were more options for
and there are becoming more and more
options for technology
yeah there are there is technology
that's that's coming out
where you won't be as as reliant on all
the massive companies at least i'm
hopeful
i don't think that's good for anyone but
i am concerned and i am sympathetic to
big tech's
worry about misinformation mal
information and disinformation
that's very dangerous but that's always
been out there like oh you could always
listen to an idiot
i know but say you have a platform say
you say your facebook
okay and and you you you have a
technology that you've invented
okay and everybody's on facebook and all
of a sudden the government of a country
because it's worldwide the government of
that country says
they start planting stories on facebook
that you know are categorically false
that are demonizing a minority um
political group because they might be
the hugers they might be the rohingya
they might be whatever in certain
countries
yeah and you go and you start talking
about how
how they they kill children or they you
do whatever to rouse up
the majority in your country's ire to
rouse up their anger
and you just start planting fake stories
and you get more and more people more
and more outraged
about cnn whatever it might be and now
you have now you have a
vigilante mob of 5 000 that have all
been talking on facebook
and they decide let's go kill these
rohingya
right these eugers these uh
these trans people these these
republicans or these democrats over here
or these liberals or these conservatives
over here right
history is full of that i mean the tsar
in russia when the economy and [ __ ] was
going bad
he would say you know what let's blame
the jews
let's go hey hey hey all you guys it's
the jews that are doing this
so you'd have mobs of of men with
bats and knives and they would come into
the jewish pales the ghetto
and [ __ ] burn down the synagogue and
kill as many people as they could and
rape everybody and do all kinds of
horrible things
that was the story of the jew in russia
forever and that's where the zionist
movement was born
the idea was if this is going to keep
happening we're going to keep getting
killed
we need a homeland we need a homeland we
have nowhere to go because we're always
a minority
so what i'm saying is that now with
facebook
and with big tech if you're allowed to
spread it from if you're really
organized about it
and you're allowed to spread information
that is categorically false
but it's also galvanizing an enemy
galvanizing people to actually take
violent action
right like people that trade pokemon
cards almost but they're what if they're
doing it which apparently they were i
think at the rohingya i think in burma
or whatever
myanmar came from so people were really
doing this they was meeting on facebook
groups and then
for having a beliefs and then going out
and taking action yes
so now so now you have someone like mark
zuckerberg what's zuckerberg and all of
them supposed to do
they're responsible they're looking at
the moral responsibility they're looking
at the
they're looking at all the
responsibility looking at the financial
i mean
the legal responsibility but it's also
just a moral thing but also a problem
because they don't know how to deal with
that
i wouldn't know how to deal with that
how the [ __ ] do you deal with that so
now you got to get really really kind of
uh
you've got to get really draconian about
it now you got to be like look if you
guys are going to start talking about
uh masks that aren't not being effective
are you going to start talking about how
vaccines are not effective which by the
way they are effective
if you're going to start talking about
that and you're gonna start spreading
all these like
documentaries that don't have any basis
in science i'm just using as an example
i guarantee i'll get a lot of [ __ ] just
for saying that but but
if you keep doing that right um
they have to kind of go the science is
saying this
and you guys are saying this they have
to take a stand
right but then you're going to be stuck
by by what that person's views of the
world are and what they
tough like because what if they have a
total their upbringing is totally
they live for from a complete different
place and i think you have a lot of
these people are all from the same spot
the same type of tribe and the same type
of
you know uh there are a lot of the same
just type of people
yeah so so i just did an interview with
milk yeah i did an interview with
aleister bostwick
it's on youtube now and he's he's uh he
was a reporter for huffington post
for buzzfeed and now he works for
verizon.com which is he kind of like
you know he's a really good journalist
he just did a crazy video on on woody
allen and how one sided that piece was
on on woody allen i mean he's basically
defending woody allen but you know just
a liberal guy
but he said he was talking about how i
said to him i said
why is the press so left wing and he
goes because most of the people who are
in the press are from
la and new york and chicago and the big
cities
and they just happen to be younger
people who tend to lean left it's not
like a conspiracy
they said they tend to be socially
progressive and so what you're going to
get is you're going to get
more people in journalism who happen to
be of that
the way he was describing it was really
right that makes sense kind of yeah so
like you said it's the same ilk if you
have if you have one particular ilk and
they're usually educated
they're usually super educated from
really good schools and they tend to
come from socioeconomic backgrounds that
are of higher
class right so they have a different but
that perspective of the world
growing up like like dude some of my
richest friends have been the absolute
most scared about this pandemic uh
smartest friends have been the most
scared about this pandemic
that it's just ridiculous you know like
exactly so i think there's a level there
too where it's just so overkill
and so out of touch with what like a
regular working day-to-day
man and woman couple yeah that wants to
have a traditional kind of lifestyle
yes and then everything is this but then
you have a lot of those types of people
who are far left who end up being
40 year old women who are lonely who
have no [ __ ] children
and who are trying to like get you know
fly down to barbados to
jump start their wombs somehow on some
fabled machine or something you know or
wandering around their house and dying
their hair [ __ ] 75 colors and [ __ ]
sawing their tits off for magic or
whatever like it just gets
so then you have a lot you have a lot of
people who are just
unspoken for and who feel unspoken for
even just to ask questions and then
that's where it gets really really
spooky
well you know you ever heard the
expression weird so so
because i'm not like some right-wing
trumper but also i'm a person who
believes i should be able to talk about
stuff
and ask questions and not feel weird if
i want to for
also say stuff and get something wrong i
agree like how else do you
even i agree be a comedian the whole
but just so scary that you're even
having to be careful like we are both
very careful right now on a podcast
about what we're saying and how we're
talking that never used i have to be
careful because i don't know what i'm
saying a lot of times too so my brain is
very careful because it doesn't know
what i'm talking about a lot of times
but
like you said you're allowed to be
you're allowed to get it wrong
right but so now you have a gr you have
a society people they feel like they're
not allowed to get anything
at least to trial and error that's right
you have a ton of people that feel that
way
yeah how does that feel to some i mean
uh it's just that's debilitating
that's debilitating to people it is
debilitating it's awful
i mean it's funny because when they did
any experiment they ever did right
so if you think about like um anything
you know frankenstein well no
any that would be one frankenstein is a
good
the man tried it on his brother look at
louis van gaal look at
uh do you know you know what
frankenstein symbolized
the idea that machines were taking over
machines were now taking over humanity
wow we're having the same talk
100 years later about how machines are
going to take over
and and make man obsolete that was
something that
that mary shelley who wrote that book
was that was the thesis of that book
like
when man meshes with machine we'll lose
our humanity
it's kind of [ __ ] you know cyclical
but most of
most of the studies on economics on
social behavior
on social we all talk about whatever it
might be like you know when you say
things like
well most people you know most people
tend to be more emotional about this
it was all done on what they call
their acronym is weird western um
industrialized educated rich
developed uh people from those countries
from westernized educated industrialized
rich developed countries so most
professors were doing their their
[ __ ]
experiments on people who are college
educated
or at least you know uh had had money
were
from a developed country definitely like
europe or america
there was never any of it done on people
who came from other parts of the world
who didn't come from
industrialized developed educated
backgrounds
so so much of what we know is is has
been skewed just by the nature of how
experimentation was done and who is
available to do the experiments on
you know what i'm saying yeah it's like
that so we we keep running into these
issues
we keep running into these issues yeah
man look it's it's spooky time to be
it's like is it spooky it's a great time
to be alive it's the only time that we
get
that we know of right now i'm scared
it's also it's a
it's a scary time um but there has to be
there's always like a way out of things
it's like
i mean for example like you know you can
still
if you shut yourself off to some of the
media
and you just let it go and do its thing
you can
still live a normal
uh straight yeah
life or gay life whichever you want
you don't have to get into the fights
you don't have to engage in it
because some of it is out of my control
yeah
but then also it's like every voice that
was even like questioning or anything
is has been extremely silenced
and that's not good you know i don't
feel like that that kind of stuff is
good no
that's the problem the other argument
like sam tripley and i always have these
arguments on
oh i've talked to sam dude oh it's great
but we we have this podcast conspiracy
social club
and i debunk conspiracies right he seems
to win a lot but
by the way by the way if you watch
conspiracy social club i think we may
have to move
over to rockfin because they took us off
vimeo really patreon didn't let us do
that yeah because they don't allow any
conspiracy talk even though i debunk it
vimeo should be lucky to have anybody on
that [ __ ] i know but they took us
down because they have a strict policy
against
and i'm like i'm an anti-conspiracist
i'm trying to debunk it
but you know they're like no you know so
i you know i i don't know what they're
yeah i don't know what the practice well
it's just become general and blanket
which is crazy because that's the same
thing that they that that
like like kind of left
leaning things say that people are doing
about gender and stuff but you're doing
it
in the term the term words that you use
to terminate like anything that pops up
yeah and i'm trying to in earnest debunk
conspiracy that breaks my heart and and
uh you know so we have to go that's why
you got to get a glock dude you got to
get your family have one and go
be somewhere i know you know and i think
that's what a lot of people a lot of
people are saying this rat race
doesn't even accept me anymore
they not only that but they mistreat me
on social platforms where i'm even just
trying to be
a regular person who errors
and who is human honey man and trying to
be funny or just trying to be human
yeah like and it's just a lot of it is
people who
never wanted to take any risks just
sitting somewhere
flowing into this they're going to
always exist though it's the problem is
corporations the money
listens right the money
you know until consumers that's why you
need to get an app that sends people to
different places
they can support companies that
also mimic some of their beliefs or at
least
are open to it because then once it
starts to affect
the pocketbooks of companies they'll
quit the [ __ ] how about due process
how about just that
how about so so so you know if disney's
gonna completely cancel gina carano for
writing bebop boop and just
and having a clumsy comparison to the
holocaust which wasn't even that clumsy
compared to a lot of people who are on
the left who didn't get cancelled
yeah you know if you're going to do that
then then until consumers
say i'm not i'm not upping my
subscription to disney i'm not watching
lucasfilms anymore
right until they do that and until
disney sees that that
when they cancel someone like gina
carano or they cancel anybody due to due
process
they get it actually hurts their dollar
it actually hurts their sales because
right now they just don't want to deal
with
any kind of twitter thing but it's so
crazy who gives a [ __ ] about
it's just like they do because they
don't want to deal with the backlash
because those voices are so loud and
they'll go away in a week yeah not
not when but it's just it creates
too much bad press because what what
does the press do the press needs clicks
the press everybody in the press talking
to aleister bosworth again
about this he's like it when you're when
you're a [ __ ] journalist
you want clicks you want to create
sensation
you're right you want it right right
yeah right you you can't do if you're
going to do a documentary on mia farrow
and woody allen
you can't take a balanced approach
nobody wants to see it they want you
want a hit piece the way the michael
jackson thing was
you got to you got to come up you got to
come hard from one angle right
because then we're like yeah we got a
bad guy and a good guy right so this is
and then this is dustin poirier taught
me this man he said
this is when that mike perry thing came
up mike perry had done some things he
was kind of losing
losing it he was going through a tough
moment like about eight months ago or a
year ago
and i was talking to dust one time he
goes you know man i don't click on that
kind of stuff when people send me that
kind of stuff i don't click on it
because i don't want that in my world he
said
i don't want that in my world i don't
want to look at people that i care about
or other humans in ways where people
are just um trying to pinpoint them into
one little space or one little moment
good for him he just said it's not fair
and so
since then i've tried to stay off of
like when people sent that kind of [ __ ]
don't send me that it but it's it's like
this porn we're
we use it as porn yes so as long as we
keep doing that yes
it's that's kind of stuff's gonna keep
happening as long as you keep rewarding
right cancel culture and you do it by
clicks we do that by clicks
when you click on it yeah that then you
[ __ ] saying i support this even if
you don't
that's right that's what's crazy so
that's where the weird addiction comes
in it's like
we're just just also like look like the
fact that disney makes amazing products
and my kids love their movies
when a massive company like that you
know cancel someone like gina carano
and we still you know we're still
patrons of that company
in a way we're all complicit right it's
so
hard to fight man it's hard to fight
because there's such tech is the new
fossil fuel man
yeah that's the oil what happened with
this this country singer who used the
n-word
he didn't really i think people kind of
galvanized did people kind of go
this is too much or what happened he's a
i mean morgan's a friend of mine he was
on a podcast
he was on a couple months ago he used it
he called his friend the n-word in the
street he came back and apologized he
said
i'm gonna try to do better and you know
the media did what they did they ripped
him up
what got me about that i mean obviously
like
it's like he called his friend [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] right to a white dude and i think
a lot of white people should be called
the n-word
i got called it a bunch growing up i
still get called it sometimes by this
dude that lives in the park the black
guy by me will call me every now and
then
i like it a little i'll be honest that's
who i am makes you feel included
yeah it does something bro you know like
sometimes
no joke i was walking with a girl a
couple weeks ago and the guy said it
and i know she didn't hear him and i
[ __ ] said hey say it louder bro
you know and he did and he said it
louder bro he's a black guy he can say
it right he can like in a way you feel
like he trusts you
and he knows that you're not a
prejudiced white guy right he knows i'm
not a spock
in a way he feels like he's he's saying
it's like a tournament of endearment
for you like yeah it was like a code i
got to wear for a couple seconds gave me
a little bit of clout with the dame you
know
or the man whatever she was i don't know
what she's chosen to be i didn't check
i'm glad you cleared that but um yeah
but what got me was that
and this and and i'm is that suddenly
there were news articles that would
never even
watch morgan that was the guy's name
yeah
that would never even and they're
they're using it in their titling like
the n word the n word so they're
basically using the n word to get you to
go
of course so who's really using it one
guy who uses it on the street calling
his white friend
or the white press that makes money by
getting clicks that's what burn
and it's like man all of them go
i can get the story now i can use the
n-word and now i can get we can get more
online subscriptions there's money in
clicks
yeah and as long as there's money and
clicks and there's money in telling your
readers your echo chamber exactly what
they want to hear and
what they believe anyway and already
you you will you will continue to to
polarize the press
and now you look at anything that comes
out of huffington post you like i know
exactly how they feel so why am i going
to read this
right or fox oh here we go but it's like
um
here's a question but what else does
that thinking i have one more thought on
this
but it's just when they when
i mean and he came out and said for
himself you know he said you know
what he wanted to say on it so it's like
it's his thing
but some i don't know sometimes you feel
like it'd be
it's just crazy how you can go and buy
the on certain platforms you can buy the
n-word and listen to it
you know you can pay two dollars for it
1.99 for a song and go listen oh yeah
you know it's like maybe don't make it
available to white people
well i think that that this guy somehow
got like he
they tried to cancel him and i think his
fans were like now we're gonna buy all
his stuff
oh he'll have the biggest tour in the
world in a couple years
his music is just great yeah i mean i
think you know uh and he's a great kid
i was at his house a couple nights
before the video stuff
and there were black guys over there
with him he had it's not like i'm sure
i've seen racist people yeah he's not a
racist guy he's not a racist guy
so and that's obvious to most human
people with a brain
yeah but yeah but intention doesn't
matter anymore
it's just consequence what's this
question i see a guy asking a question
yeah let's get out of this sorry and i
didn't really want to talk about that
but it's okay we're just we're covering
a lot of bases right now hold on fellas
how you doing
sitting here ripped off my gourd right
now off some of those good oregon derby
shires
and got a question for you
if you had to give each other three
compliments that didn't have anything to
do with comedy or a mullet
what would they be it's a hockey haircut
first of all
that's good that's a great question
three compliments
that had nothing to do with comedy or
the mullet
i would say this oh you wanna uh who
goes first nick
uh brian okay go go one go every other
fine i'm your boss but brian
i would say i would say
that you're um i i think you have a very
original brain
and i love that about you okay and i
think i mean i'm not allowed to talk
about comedy but
it it's it's very difficult to separate
your you see you have what's called
original expression you're just original
you're an original generally and that's
so [ __ ] rare
and then i think you're um you're very
loyal
you're a loyal [ __ ] dude and you
um also have overcome
something i think most people don't even
understand
i mean i think what you've overcome over
your family
your mother and all that i don't think
anybody realizes how huge that is
i don't and i think that's that always
is going to be
something that you're contending with
but the wrestle
you know that jacob's ladder thing when
he wrestled the angel the angel that you
wrestle on a day-to-day basis
is what makes and you're winning that
you're winning whether you know it or
not you win it every day and it's
it it actually makes the world a better
place so your
trauma and i believe it's trauma i
really do i've watched your old stuff
when you were young talking about your
life and your childhood
the trauma that you went through has not
beaten you
it has made the world a better place
that's why people love you and i don't
think
you would be who you are without the
irony is you wouldn't be who you are
without that that almost impossible
thing to deal with
that that thing that would break most
people and
it you never let it you just turned it
into something
very special so that's my compliment
those are my three compliments for theo
vaughn
that's why yeah well thank you bro
that's sweet of you to say man uh you're
gonna find three things on me this is
cashmere though
i don't know if i'm gonna i mean you're
such a good expressionist man
um i would say for one i would say
you're
uh your
ability to take a moment to give
valuable interaction is something that
is very rare um
i've had a couple moments with you over
the years that i can remember
even one of the first ones going back to
uh at the
uh bruco when you told me
i was asking you something about comedy
and you know and you had a conversation
with me just about learning as much as i
could you know and just you know if
you'll learn as much as you can then
you'll have so much
so many uh tools to
be comedic from you know um
to even things now from growing up to
recommend in books
um you know just different things if i'm
going through
like yeah sharing stuff like different
you know experiences from childhood
trauma and one
wanting to like discuss that and needing
some support
um you know you actually like even if it
takes a day or something for you to call
back or to get back when you do
you give uh some time that's real
um that really feels
uh valuable and important and so i don't
want to say thank you for that man it's
really sweet of you
okay um because when i hear you i hear
somebody that
it's like a voice that like a male voice
that's educated that i did
never just and is like
kind of educated but also good at
injecting it into
the flow of
immediate life and so it's hard to do
that it's such a
skill that so few people have um
so thank you i'm lucky to be privileged
to see some of that and to experience it
firsthand
um outside of that i would say
probably symmetrical i would say
symmetrical probably
i would go with that and it doesn't have
anything to do with hair i would say
symmetrical
uh i would say
um your your vitality
for life i think you stay you're like a
[ __ ]
vain you know is what you are
you're like keep moving keep moving yeah
no matter what happens
keep growing keep moving you're you're
don't stop moral
you're a [ __ ] femoral vein dude
you're rolling through the big bones you
can't stop you know what i'm saying you
ain't out of here in a damn tarpal
you know what i'm saying picasso said
picasso said i think he called it
sweeping the alley like picasso was like
no matter what famine karate or
all that keep painting keep painting
keep painting that's crazy so when he's
90 years old he was painting on the
level he was painting at when he was 40
for real
i went to i went to his i meant to a of
a show that he had
it was his work i think he did it when
he was 90. and i would listen to the
the you know art historian explain what
he was doing
i was like this [ __ ] is 90
and he's he was painting on the level
that's beyond
like he was still doing it at the
highest level
that's crazy i was like if that's the
case if that's where the bar is man
i'm [ __ ] i can never stop yeah but
they're
you know it's hard i just hope i'm
allowed to you know you just keep hoping
that you
in one way or another can can continue
to be
expressive and continue to do what you
love yeah
like i never like i mean i'm i'm you
know not an idiot but i'm definitely
i'll be
you know i'm i will mill around with
idiots bro and i will definitely
read books i've read six or seven times
dude and not know what happened that
happened that's normal
okay come on man but uh what i'm saying
is that
[ __ ] man i forgot about it but uh it's
it's uh i said i was a vain
i was femoral i was a female yeah okay
femoral vein
so that's two i think those are two
things i think a femoral artery
okay vein i think the difference is what
an artery
that an artery comes out it goes and
arteries yeah it's from the heart and
it's
um yeah yeah you're not like
that artery is more of like a
a it's more of a super highway yeah
you're a little bit more of that service
road
am i yeah kind of like bumpy a little
bumpy yeah there's definitely some
potholes there's some potholes there's
some zoning issues you can't be you
can't be a smooth highway and be a comic
no you can't you gotta have you gotta
have all you gotta have some plaque up
there there's some left turns or
something like
dead ends you got some varicose [ __ ] you
got some backed up
yeah some backed up like coagulated
blood there's some plavacid
in the [ __ ] yeah i don't even know
what plavis it is but you gotta have
some [ __ ] you can't identify this big
pharma is [ __ ] starting to play a
role in this plan
what the [ __ ] is that we don't know we
don't know but put on your mask because
we gotta get through this [ __ ] right now
your grandparents are dying jim brewer
has this great bit now he's like
grandmother's dying it's like he's
[ __ ]
impersonating a nazi [ __ ] i love him
i love yeah you know as you get older
i'll tell you this i'm a lot older than
you and you get less sure
of of uh any kind of a truth
really in a way now that's another thing
i was gonna ask you how does aging
happen
in your beliefs and in your thoughts
like what starts to happen
you you know i i tend to become more
um i tend to become more compassionate
for people who have a totally different
point of view than i do right
wow so i'm i'm a white straight male
right fine
i'm not saying you have it easy if
you're a white straight male i'm not
saying but i'm saying that if i was a
black woman
if i was uh if i was
a native american from or an indigenous
person a first nation person from
winnipeg if i was from a small indian
village in the south of india
i would have a very different point of
view
that's true on the world on what's right
on what's wrong on what's fair what's
unfair
on what i was afraid of and what i
wasn't afraid of
if i was a black man for the most part
even if i had money
even if i was privileged with an
education yeah if i drove by
i know this if i was driving by two
white cops
okay maybe not now but certainly
nine months ago right i would have
turned my music down
i would have put my glasses on i might
have rolled my window down
set my wallet on the dashboard whatever
it is right
right whatever it is a little bit like
the way we talk now about anything
that's
that's considered politically incorrect
we're now aware that big tech might shut
us off
right that was what it's like that's
what it was like always so as i get
older
and i read more and i and i try to take
that perspective of i don't know
it tends to make me a little bit more
compassionate and a little less attached
to my
cognitive beliefs because i know how my
brain works right it's
from reading my brain works like this
i'm an emotional creature
so i have a set of beliefs that were
given to me
by people i loved like my mother and my
father like the culture i come from
and media like what worked for me and
media right
so i have a set of beliefs like this and
so what happens is when you have that
set of beliefs
you're going to try to find evidence to
support your beliefs
so if you start talking about socialism
i'm automatically going to have an
argument
right i'm a capitalist quote-unquote or
i'm a free-market guy
right i'm a libertarian but then i
then i'll read a book and i realized
that a lot of the basis of what i'm
making all my philosophy on is
not necessarily grounded in evidence and
that somebody over there
who has a different point of view has
something to offer me
has something to enlighten me on so this
is a process so i guess what i'm saying
is that as i get older i realize i'm a
work in progress
don't be too attached to
everything you believe i love that don't
don't be so sure that everything you
know and believe is true okay that's
really important
and be willing to change your mind based
on evidence
and be able to see the evidence when
it's in front of you
well right i agree with you man and i
think a lot of and i've even noticed in
my own life over the past nine months
over the past year
i've gotten very a lot of people are
very stuck to their what their
their beliefs because it's some of it's
a safety mechanism
yes they feel attacked they feel like
they don't know the other side weaponry
over there
right yeah right so yeah it's like you
start to feel
um and you feel like they're not doing
that so why do i have to
you know it's like uh
it's interesting how like a lot of that
flint has flared up over the past year
well there's a documentary on
netflix called crack and remember crack
babies
crack baby okay i know a guy that was
all the time [ __ ]
that was all [ __ ] there were no
crack babies crack crack babies weren't
born that way
most of the time it was a woman a woman
who was
doing drinking marijuana but it wasn't
that crack itself was creating a whole
generation of
kids who are addicted to cocaine that's
not oh yeah i never heard that i just
heard like if you had a real skinny baby
and he had jewelry on
but yeah but again that's what i always
heard
again you can you can also add to that
black baby you can also add that black
woman giving birth to black baby
right so what happened with the crack at
them epidemics i said your crack baby's
born to a mother
who's addicted to the crack now i
promise you in
every americans every white americans at
the media
and even movies like like boys in the
hood
the woman was holding a baby
and saying something like i'll do
whatever it takes right
crack right it was a black woman it was
always demonizing a black woman
it's just true so if you're a black
woman in the hood try to make ends meet
you can't afford to leave a battle zone
and you're trying to raise your kids and
there's a thousand other things you're
dealing with
and now that's going on in the media
you're being demonized
right you know so so so because that was
the narrative
right and so you'd have a very different
perspective on america
oh i would have who you were if you were
a black woman especially living in the
80s
my generation my generation how the [ __ ]
wouldn't you have a chip on your
shoulder oh
dude yeah look i think about that a lot
of times i think sometimes there's a
people don't realize like i've talked to
before about like disney world like you
see the
the advertising for disney world there
was always white kids at disney world
yeah so if you're a black kid and you're
watching that how would you not feel
like oh this isn't even for me you
weren't represented in in cartoons
right anything well but there's some
stuff is that that's not entirely true
like some of my favorite shows were
black
acted shows so like you know you had
samford and son you had in the heat of
the night which had a
black characters in it some of my
favorite um althea tibs is one of my
favorite
characters ever from uh from a drama you
know they had a lot of
uh and what was the one um and i know
i'm just saying the one but there was a
lot there was the one with the cops
there was cosby which was huge
that did a lot that was like oh look
there's a black family just like a white
family there's a black doctor
they said he's in my living room every
day you know that was that whole that
was that
that was an important show in that sense
but i could imagine yeah but when i was
growing up there wasn't any black
doctors in our town no
well i so this is where i get i get the
i get
where black activists where white
you know activists where woke people are
coming from
if you actually look at the history of
this country
just go back 20 years 15 years see i
don't i'm not
liberal this way i'm not like a woke
person i do like fair play though
i've always wanted exactly fair if you
show me where something's not fair
i'm right there i'm like i got it i get
it i get it
oh man i remember putting a jesse
jackson sign out in front of our
apartment growing up
like i remember um i was a david dukakis
fan like
i really resonated with a lot of people
i say david duke
oh i used to lift weights of david duke
everybody knows that though did you yeah
you worked out with david duke yeah he
shared a fence dude he used to date the
hottest chick at the seafood restaurant
i worked at is that right
god you you lived near david duke she
was hot
yeah still my folks still share a back
fence not far from them that's hilarious
david they call him d duke around the
neighborhood d duke
he's a beautiful little uh pomeranian
white
i won't say that but yeah that would
make sense um
but yeah there's just a lot to it man
there's a lot to it but yeah to think
that
i think the part that gets me a lot of
times it's people it's
it's people have now become like it's
like
people use the woke stuff for clout and
it's not even about the argument anymore
and then i also start to see
i've always thought about like equality
fairness i see a lot of like black
supremacy
jewish supremacy i see some people uh
you know um indian supremacy
i see a lot i don't like privilege i
don't like supremacy
yeah i don't like it any time when
people start to get stuff into supremacy
marcellus wiley was that that guy's name
he had a great quote about it a while
back um
that's the part where it starts to make
me feel angry bro
i don't like any type of supremacy bro
like um
it just because then it's not about
everybody well you're assigning
something called
group guilt what you're doing is you're
saying that entire group is guilty
and if you do that we know how that
works out in history too right
because when you when you assign guilt
to an entire group
just for their color just for their
gender just for their uh so it's your
economic background yeah
now if you do that just remember that
you can that's a double-edged sword you
can turn that sword on the other group
just as quickly yeah if you do that to
that group when you're done with that
group
you're next you know and and so and and
what happens is if you have group
guilt then you usually have to have
a group that rectifies that guilt
and one need only look at the world
today forget history
and see how that works out for people
who are
assigned group guilt they're killed
they're jailed they're put in
concentration camps
they're they're quote unquote
marginalized in the worst way possible
so
let's all be careful about that [ __ ]
yeah that's why that's the problem with
identity politics
that's why i'm very like now one thing
i'm not on the fence on is i am very
against identity politics
i think it's [ __ ] the worst i don't
even know what it is
it's the idea that you are you are you
are essentially breaking people up into
their groups
and you are assigning guilt or you are
assigning victimhood
to varying degrees to different groups i
mean that's that's what you do
and those groups that have traditionally
been in a position of quote-unquote
supremacy
or in a position of privilege have to
take now a back seat or whatever or are
like give me an example so i know what
i'm well well the idea behind
um identity politics would be you know
we have
even when you start talking about the
black vote versus the asian vote
versus the white vote you're already
creating groups you're already saying
that you're already creating a monolith
you're suggesting that black people
think the same way like there aren't
that there are people it's hard not to
do that
first as it gets right but also when you
start doing that when you start when you
start
saying we need a quota we need
representation from this group because
this group has been left
out you're playing a form of identity
politics
because when you do that when you when
you privilege one group over the other
or you start detracting just based on
group
not based on skill based on biological
attributes you have to have an enforcing
mechanism you have to have
someone at the top who has the power to
make those decisions
to enforce those decisions that is a
that is a
that is something you must do through
force you must do
at the end of the day at the barrel of a
gun damn
because that's what the state does if i
say no they say yes
if i really refuse to move you get
dragged out
by officers of the law right
they happen to have guns at the end of
the day there's no way to do that
without
some form of coercion some form of force
when you do that
and you and you and you demonize one
group
or you start to say this group is a
victim and this group has to pay for
that
what happens is you're going to push
people you're going to really push
people into groups
what you're going to do is you're going
to create the the you're going to
america will become
what a prison yard is what what what
what a state penitentiary becomes
where you've got the aryan brotherhood
over here you've got the southern
mexicans you've got the northern
mexicans you got the black
you got this whole thing over here and
all of a sudden you create and now
you're now now the only consideration
is color and you have people that are so
obsessed with color
it's like they should be an art school
they should be in art school making
studying oil painting yeah because
that's the only criteria
and so it's a very again it's a very
rudimentary very dangerous game to play
and i i'm not nearly as articulate about
this no it's helpful
for me it's great though because it's
good because it's like yeah this is good
practice because jordan peterson it's
like damn it's like somebody just beat
you in the face with a [ __ ] library
and talking about this you know i did i
did the first podcast with him
really yeah that's when rogan called
text me and said
um your podcast jordan peterson was
great he had he had just heard about him
and i did
you and jordan peterson rogan together
no i did the first podcast with him in
our group
no rogan rogan then put him on dang
that's crazy
yeah how about that wow
yeah man and it was so great
i've done three podcasts with them i
think so it's such an honor
i love that guy yeah i feel pretty
excited i'm trying to think of good
questions like just to ask and just
things that i'm like thinking about
things that i'm scared about yeah i'm
gonna read the book yeah but also just
things that like i'm just worried about
and
or just like just looking for sometimes
guidance you know
yeah sometimes when you get someone that
has more experience what i like to try
to do sometimes
to get some guidance so how do we how do
we stay away from identity politics and
stuff like that what can we do
and how do we stay funny what can we do
to stay funny in a time like this
you have to fight back you have to um
you have to recognize first of all where
identity politics came from
you have to recognize you have to
recognize what the other side
that pushes that stuff is trying to do
you have to have
you have to have better ideas you have
to remember
that what has worked for the most part
with the west
and what other countries have not done
is that they treat people as individuals
okay you treat everyone as an individual
you treat when someone comes in for a
job whether they are trans whether they
are black whether they are native
american whether they are
straight white guy india i want to see
what you can do
let me let me try and it's very and what
they'll tell you is there's unconscious
bias
okay so they say if you're white you're
unconsciously going to be biased towards
someone who's white okay
fine that's true i don't either but but
but this is the new thing so you have
anti-bias training here's the problem
with anti-bias training here's the
biggest problem
so the idea is you have some expert
who's taking some classes in the
humanities
and and you know and they come in and
they apparently are the experts on how
to teach you about your unconscious bias
okay
the idea then would be you take a class
and now you don't have any
either you don't have unconscious bias
or you're aware that you have
unconscious body because
okay all good the problem is you'll
never take unconscious bias out of a
human being and by the way unconscious
bias is very important and a very good
thing most of the time or some of the
time why
if somebody has shifty eyes and clammy
hands i'm not [ __ ] they're on
you money or i'm not gonna hire you for
the job because you're sketchy i can't
explain why
yeah but you give my gut you give my gut
my intuition uh the notion that you
ain't no good
yeah and i need that because that's how
i keep my money that's how i keep
safe i keep my family safe yeah well
that's how women keep from [ __ ]
keep state stay safe when they see a guy
who's something
something's over there so my mother told
me that one time she goes out there was
a guy
and the way he was standing i knew he
was he was looking to get jump me
i knew he was looking to rape me oh yeah
and so my mother was like she just
she got a bad feeling and turned and
walked the other way
and blah blah so so we need our
unconscious
yeah you can't walk into a dark alley
filled with people like bad wolves
and just be like maybe they're good
wolves you know the guy at the
at the at the meeting said maybe they're
good wolves give them a chance
one of them is loading a gun and
chiseling your name into the side of it
this is where critical race theory comes
in this is that this is all
comes out of the same idea that's not
enough to be not racist you have to be
actually
actively tearing down the institutions
that have given us the longest standing
democracy in the history of the world
you got to start tearing down
institutions dude i grew up like the
nuclear family apparently is bad now
yeah that's insane and that's what's
causing a lot i mean a lot of it is
people don't have any faith anymore
there's nothing
there's nowhere to turn we could go into
all of it
yeah it's it's being talked about at
least and even even a couple of
knuckleheads like us are actually
talking about
[ __ ] this i didn't i wanted to get into
something funny i [ __ ] up
no no it's all good this could be funny
i don't know
okay here's a guy right here and this
guy might be black might be white this
dude might be jehovah's witnesses he's a
composite man
what up theo brian bright guy
the original kid callin yeah bry
we just saw wanna know probably um you
spent a lot of time
away we all we personally missed you
i'm sure a lot of other people did too
and i think we're just all really
curious like what did you do during
that time like i uh what happened
like give us an update i think we're all
really wanting to know how you spent
that time
in gang yeah what have you been doing
brian great question
starting a podcast with steve burns big
and hungry and hungry yeah which i was
on
yes you were which is awesome drops
every monday
when's our episode coming out uh i think
i think this monday okay and it's
[ __ ] hilarious okay i killed it cool
cool
and then you guys got yep that's big and
hungry anywhere you find podcasts
i've been doing the conspiracy social
club with sam tripoli
twice a week and that's been interesting
because now we might have to move over
to another platform
rockfin because we too hot way too too
hot
for vimeo but that's good maybe
something like rockfin starts up
yeah i wish we would all start our own
platform but yeah
you know and i just kept you know i was
dealing with a lot of [ __ ] so i just
kept i worked out every day and i just
did you
yeah and i just tried to become a better
father and uh
you know i was i was going through a
divorce but that that ended very
amicably because me and my
ex get along really well and we we uh we
raised the kids together and
and we didn't need like we didn't need
courts and you know
we needed we needed we did some lawyer
stuff just to because it's detailed
but other than that we were we we did it
great and i'm proud of that and i'm
proud of her for that
we we we ended it really really well
because the kids are our priority
and then uh and then i don't know man i
just [ __ ] i
brushed up on my kung fu did you yeah
dude there's something about that
staying physically active how important
uh was that man it's called
communicating with your body
that's what you do so when you do a
sport or you do anything you're
communicating with your body
you you you know it only gets harder as
you get older oh yeah yeah but that's
almost the point
like embracing the suck you don't have
to work out an hour dude you can [ __ ]
lift for 20 minutes and kill you so i
worked out for 15 minutes yesterday i'm
sore as [ __ ]
but but the way you do it is is what
matters but then you do a sport
get good at something man i always say
this people if you're young
get good i don't give a [ __ ] if it's
salsa dancing
if you get really good at salsa dancing
it will open up a whole world for you if
you get really good at jiu jitsu if you
get really good at the flute
i don't give a [ __ ] what it is if you
get really good at anything
that that requires like practice on a
daily basis
the answers lie there yeah and then
you're going to come in contact with
other people who have gotten really good
at things
and you're going to be introduced to so
many more
things then and so and you're going to
learn from the best it's just
there is something that's so valuable
about just having spent some time doing
things
man i've been trying to get into jiu
jitsu more you know um and i'm really
enjoying it i'm a white belt
currently wipeout white belt nation
white belt nation dude also
hard scarf club and um i
uh i'm looking to compete maybe at some
point that's great
i don't know if i'll compete this year
yeah but
the hardest part people don't realize at
my age i have to do
yoga probably four times a week to stay
in enough
of us comfortable physical space to then
be able to go
even to the jiu jitsu class so it's like
there's so much that has to happen
outside of the place yeah um
but i started eating liver uh liver
crisps
like liver jerky yeah to get my
i mean i'll [ __ ] dude i got a damn
menstrual cycle in the back of my throat
half the week dawg i'm [ __ ] ready to
go son let's [ __ ] go straight
i could spit in the air and a [ __ ]
waffle show up and catch it i'm
ready to go so i've been trying to
challenge myself a little bit more in
that space
and then yeah some of that learning in
jiu-jitsu it takes like the anger that's
inside of me it takes it out of my body
to be trapped by another man or young
woman
and not have any [ __ ] recourse except
to scream into the [ __ ] abyss
as they're as they're imposing their
will on you of a [ __ ] gym where
people are laughing
i can't breathe that's amazing oh look
at theo von getting tapped
yeah it's so good for you look at him
getting tapped by this bus girl from
olive garden
yeah it's so good for you though [ __ ]
like that where you're not
i think that's the best thing you do for
your comments oh it's great you practice
[ __ ] that you're not good at and you're
having to like readjust your neural
pathways and stuff
it's like doing lsd man all of a sudden
you're going to be thinking about [ __ ]
differently yeah like you're just not
comfortable
yeah being comfortable comfort might be
the wolf at the door
comfort look we've said it on this this
podcast before comfort will be your
coffin man it really will
and it's crazy to think that um you know
and before we go yeah like i was a
little bit nervous about having you on
just because i know you kind of been
through a lot over the past year
has it been tough to like
um has it been what's it been like for
you man
terrible has it been yeah the worst yeah
because you can't fight back
there's nothing you can do just the way
it is and like
you know it's very interesting because
you get ready for whatever
come what man life right and then
something comes along that you don't
even know how to fight against how the
[ __ ] do you fight
something like that how do you do how in
the world do you
when you never in a million years
thought something like that would happen
in a million years because you've tried
to live your life
the best you know right helping
everybody and i don't know i can just
only
i'm not i'm not spiritual enough but you
got to just kind of figure out how to
pivot but it's real
and it's got lasting consequences and
it's it's
true destruction but the question is who
are you in
destruction who are you when chaos hits
who are you when
everything is taken from you that you've
built over 30 years
and i don't know but i'm finding out you
know at least i'm tough at least i know
who the [ __ ] i am and
and and you know that's the other thing
i've talked to people who've been
through this and
one one of a dear friend of mine said
the good news is you know who you are
and you know what you've done and you
sure as [ __ ] know what you haven't done
and that's what's kept me going that's
why i keep moving
that's why i'm not quiet about things
because i know who i am and i'm a good
person
and i've done everything i can to try to
make the world a better place and i'll
keep doing that the biggest thing is not
letting it take the funny away from you
that's a [ __ ] my biggest
accomplishment has been i wrote a whole
hour
in this insanity and i was funny and i
did a good [ __ ] job
and i'll keep doing that you know that
that's that's been
you know when you can suffer well suffer
well wow
suffer with dignity and suffer
productively
and criticize by creating keep
criticizing by creating
don't criticize by complaining don't
criticize by you know
what this person did that to me that's
always going to exist i just got hit
okay now what that's good for me to hear
man because i do that sometimes i'll
fall
especially in this past year and i think
a lot of us have we've fallen into the
complain and the fear and this
the outburst and the speak but yet to be
able to stay creative
um that's it man was there ever did has
there ever been any like
actual court case or anything that's
followed up from the accusations no not
at all okay
not at all and uh because
you're talking about an accusation that
was is 21 years old dude
this is somebody i don't want to get
into the details but right
yeah and i'm not trying to get you into
it i just wanted to know this is
somebody i
i mean it's insane
i don't know what happened and i'm not
interested in speculating on that
um but there was never like a there
hasn't been like a court case there's
not like a
no because absolutely not
right well that's two things there's one
thing that's ready for this that didn't
do it
right right right there's there's always
that the good news is right i didn't do
it
and that's that's and i mean you know i
i'm always hesitant to say this but the
number of
women and i put it in a drop box and i
sent it to my lawyer and my
my publicist the number of women that
have been in my life
over the past 25 years that reached out
without me
doing anything one of a couple of are
high profile
who've gone through this stuff with
harvey weinstein wow
the number of women that actually
reached out to me and said i can't
believe this is happening to you
was so heartening to me i put them all
all the texts these people i hadn't
heard from for 10 years 15 years
when you hear it from that many people
and
you know and you get to hear it put it
all in i have it all saved
i have it all saved i have it all saved
it's pretty devastating
it's pretty cool to have that many
people that you never even
reached out to reach out to you then you
have some people you haven't talked to
in
10 and 15 years and say hey you were a
good guy
like i can't believe this is happening
to you and i'll be a witness for you you
know that's like
you know that that's that's what i hold
on to those kinds of things
but sometimes when somebody writes an
article it never goes away
they just you know your reputation in
many ways is destroyed
in certain circum circles or or it shuts
off your ability to do anything in
certain facets
right and so okay that happened
now what now what let's move forward
yeah but i'm never gonna shy from it i'm
never shying from it
and i'm never gonna hide and i'm never
gonna put my head down
because i know who i am and i know the
truth and that's
and jordan peterson says in chaos all
you can do is tell the truth
damn and you know and that's what i said
to my [ __ ] the first thing i said to
my lawyer and my publicist
i go i need to know that you guys know
that i'm innocent i don't want i'm not i
don't want a hired gun
i don't want anybody who doesn't believe
fully that that this is
you know and so i i provided them with
the evidence
but that's okay well i'm sorry for not
being bra like just trying to be braver
to be more supportive
not your job that this is a very scary
time so i'll stop you right there
this is a very scary time for everybody
because if they can come for me they can
come for anybody well i just wanted to
be able to at least to be able to have a
place where people can be heard
whatever they're to have a discussion or
just to be
to be heard about like yeah it just felt
like you'd never
even had a chance to be heard in some
way oh you you're not
you're not you know it's it's just it's
it's
we have built a world where due process
doesn't exist
we have built a world where like it or
not and there's arguments on both sides
where allegations alone
ruin everything allegations alone
destroy your life
and that's a fact and and you know i
always
i really want to spooky man well it's
it's it's
not good for anyone not [ __ ]
halloween it's not for your brother
not for your father not for your friend
it ain't and again
i always say this you know if you want
to build a world like that where there's
no due process
where the court of public opinion can
destroy your ability to feed your
children
you're next yeah i always say that so
you know oh yeah i i i i just don't see
how that
ends i don't see how that that ends well
um well it just gives all the power to
one side
and that's an imbalance of power is
never good so
we're we're trying to figure it out
we're all trying to figure it out
well yeah i appreciate you being here
today man and making me feel you know
and just you know talking to me about it
and and also just talking about just
whatever man you know i love you i've
always
i've always felt like you've instilled
power in me man
really yeah i really do well i believe
in you and you're worth it
and i always tell you that when you get
down on yourself you're [ __ ]
important
you're important to my friend you
this the [ __ ] you do it's so important
to people
you know why because they laugh and you
know what happens when you laugh
you know what happens when theo vaughn
makes people laugh they forget
they're human they forget they have to
go to the bathroom they forget they're
broke
they forget they hate their job they
forget that they
are uh that their their girlfriend's
cheating on them they forget that they
were abused
they forget it all because when you make
people laugh people just they forget
that for a second
and it's and and they forget that they
uh have to even sleep
i appreciate you crying over because
it's it's it's important that you hear
that
you are important thanks your job is
important well i appreciate you always
making me feel important bro
yeah man and thank you guys man for just
even letting me start doing podcasting
man
yeah you were undeniable how the [ __ ]
how how are we going to deny you
you're just too undeniable and you put
your [ __ ] time in man
how much how many years did you put in
including your childhood that made you
the comic that you are
oh yeah if you include childhood dude a
decent amount of years dude
the bed wet until 30. well if you
include the [ __ ]
night shift i change my own sheets
that's why you wear those diapers that's
awesome sexy bro i remember at one point
i would take a [ __ ] like uh
towel or sheet or something and wrap it
around like this big diaper
and stuff as many t-shirts out in there
so when i pissed again it would just
absorb it and i could still just stay
asleep how long have you left the bed
for
oh he's uh no joke 30 years old was that
right yeah man i just
was just a traumatic sleeper yeah bro i
was just fighting [ __ ]
dragons people like you're going to piss
like yeah i'm going to [ __ ] piss now
they don't [ __ ]
battling a [ __ ] orca with long arms
[ __ ]
if comics are so special and unique it's
so interesting like comics like
what what what it was dude i remember i
used to wake up in the middle of the
night because i remember hearing that
animals could get you at night animals
could get you
could get other animals if if they
hadn't urinated in an area
and i would piss around my bed in a
circle from my bed
to keep the [ __ ] animals away god
damn right and it works man yeah and
there's nobody checking in with me to
make sure everything's okay
golden ring nobody coming in my room and
noticing that there's just
soggy spots in the [ __ ] floorboards
golden ring
it's a golden ring keep snakes away yeah
dude coaches black widows
bro yeah man god yeah what a [ __ ] bad
vampires i think peace keeps the
vampires away
if you're a righteous man if you're a
righteous man you piss righteous
even vampires go this piss smells good
this pill
smells like it comes out of a man who
does good a man who hates himself but
puts out good in the world and makes
other people feel that they're
that they're they're okay makes them
forget they're human
well we keep doing our best man yes sir
we keep doing our [ __ ] best
appreciate you brother yeah man i'm glad
to see you uh
big and hungry you guys can check it out
obviously and uh
one of the pioneers of podcasting right
here i'll be in jacksonville florida
comedy zone um march four five and six
zaney's march third for the live podcast
um
and where where theo vaughn will be uh
down in nashville yeah maybe i'll pop
through it
i'd love that if you came in damn it'd
be good and then we got um
i got omaha nebraska uh march 11 12 13.
and then i got huntsville alabama march
25 26 27 i think that are those dates
yeah
really stand up live have you done that
uh yeah i've done it
it's great it's great it's right it's
not far from nashville it's
yeah it's a good club i like that green
room it's right there
[Music]
all right kids thanks man god bless
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling
like these leaves i must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i
found i can feel it in my
bones but it's gonna take
a little time
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my stories
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my hands
and these rails that i've been riding on
[Music]
there